nouvelle escalade militaire entre la
turquie et la syrie deux avions de
combat syriens ont été abattus ce
dimanche par les forces turques eyes
lips dont l' agence de presse sana
la turquie qui assure vouloir éviter
toute confrontation avec la russie
annonce la poursuite de tout notre
suivre dans la région baptisée bouclier
de printemps cette opération déclenchée
fin février a été qualifiée de succès
par ankara vendredi celle syriens ont
été tués par des bombardements de
représailles menées par l'armée turque
dans le nord ouest du pays
de leur côté est la russie et l'otan
appelle au respect des accords de
cessez-le-feu signé à sotchi en 2018 le
problème chez nous c'est qu'il faut
commencer à respecter les engagements
pris et pendant un an et demi nous avons
constaté que pas grand chose n'a été
fait et que l'armée syrienne a tout à
fait le droit de d'éliminer les
terroristes nous demandons de manière
urgente un retour à l'accord de
cessez-le-feu de 2018 pour éviter que la
situation militaire non pire encore dans
la région et pour autoriser
l'intervention urgente de l'aide
humanitaire pour les personnes bloquées
à est libre le conflit a aidé l'iba
aussi de lourdes conséquences sur le
plan humanitaire selon l'onu
les affrontements déjà fait des
centaines de milliers de déplacés
les dizaines de milliers de personnes
vivent maintenant dans des abris de
fortune dans des bâtiments publics en
plein air sur le tri sous les arbres
exposés à la pluie à la neige dans le
froid glacial du rigoureux hiver syriens
pour tenter de trouver une issue à la
crise le président français a pas de la
turquie et la russie à établir un cessez
le feu durable dans la région d'idlib
ces feux que recep tayyip erdogan espère
trouver rapidement de son côté le
kremlin a affirmé que la coopération
avec ankara était d'une grande
importance
une rencontre entre vladimir poutine et
le chef d'état turc doit avoir lieu ce
jeudi à moscou pour en discuter